hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are watching
the opening scene for the new mortal
kombat movie this is
almost eight minutes very surprised they
decided to put this online especially
when the movie is available
on streaming services this friday so
really really soon but um
i'm really excited about this movie i i
you know i don't
necessarily care if it's good or not but
i think it's gonna be a lot of fun
so i figured i was gonna watch this why
not share the positivity on youtube
let's do it uh this is from nadist by
the way
it's how i'm watching this
when does the combat start happening is
my question
and is it immortal
[Music]
i always wonder how they get those
babies somebody has to agree to put that
baby in a film is there a costing
process
no idea
same dude i feel you that's me anytime
there's any suggestion that i have to
get out of it
ooh
hmm
did they make the babies cry like did
they force them to cry for the purposes
of the scene no
all right go sushima
probably wasn't gonna work out
i probably would have stayed with the
baby but i understand that this is a
film
and so this is probably a better
strategy
potentially
[Music]
it's like a save the baby by leaving it
type situation
i love him he's the cutest thing i've
ever seen
that looked really good i feel like
getting the cg right in
mortal kombat is gonna be really hard
i don't think this is necessary i don't
think you need to do this
who does this help how does this help
you accomplish your goal
not necessary all right though it's fine
you do you
she specifically said she needed two
water pockets now what's she gonna she's
dead disregard she's dead
it's fine
cheekbones my god
so sharp
[Music]
[Music]
you really took them outside and let
them sit on the ground before stabbing
them and freezing them to death huh
that looks really good though
look after your hand could get stuck
very pretty shot
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
very good
i'm into this
uh
i said this when i did the trailer
reaction but man
i don't know what it is about extreme
fake violence that makes me laugh
i always find it very funny
obviously not if it's real but it's fake
it's so over the top that i'm just
entertained
same as the games obviously bihar
well
oh
get over here he said the thing he said
the line that he's supposed to say
waited hard yup i'm into it i'm cool
with it
definitely going to watch it on friday i
might do another of the like live
podcast type things that i do sometimes
on here for um
like reviews just have three people join
me who i wouldn't normally have on the
channel to talk about it
uh i'm gonna have some pizza maybe drink
some white claws
watch some mortal kombat it's gonna be
great
yeah i don't i don't ultimately mind um
you know if it's not accurate to the
games
uh you know if it's not perfect in
dialogue if it's cheesy i just feel like
it's gonna be a lot of fun and i am on
board for that fun
ride so thank you all for watching i
will see you guys next time